ooh what what that's so cool are you
they get a little time-lapse what is so
cool hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to welcome to the
oxygen I included I didn't know they
took a snapshot like a timeline if
everything that I've done that's so nice
that almost makes me forget that we're
in horrible horrible danger and
everything is going horribly horribly
wrong park sign classifies an area as a
park or nature reserves passing through
parks will increase duplicate morale oh
that's a good idea I never would have
loved that I literally never would have
thought of that ever in the history of
forever that Oh frig we got a refridge
let's bust this thing out of there
let's build ourselves a refrige and then
we can add oh we don't have enough seats
anyway you know what we don't need a
plan in here because we need tables
we're in need two more tables so plant
is for losers plus someone might get
allergies from that can't have that in
there we got to think about everybody's
health
we don't need niceness in here that'd be
stupid and dumb all right uh that wires
doing good this wires doing good the
microbe musher is doing decently we're
getting a good amount of food not as
much as we could need I might uproot
those bristle blossoms because I really
don't have the water supply to sustain
that but at the same time maybe I don't
need to pull that much because now I've
got the refinement going which is okay I
think actually it's okay I'm not gonna
worry about it too much because at this
juncture we're doing pretty okay and the
decor is getting better that's pretty
nice not in there though Wow [ __ ] how's
the temperature doing yay yay yay yay
we're not gonna die yet okay this is
good all right so if we're not gonna die
just yet why do I have this big-ass
thing here if I'm not using it I am have
no idea um but if we're not using that
yet or if we're not gonna die just yet
that means we have time to plan
carefully our next few moves so if I'm
gonna plan carefully my next few moves
then what I need to do is
maybe it would be better to have all of
the algae in one spot and then pump the
oxygen out and then I could filter the
oxygen out in addition to the polluted
water emitting polluted oxygen
technically speaking if I use a
deodorizer for that that adds to the
oxygen that's being produced right wait
I'm not wrong about that that's that's
correct
wait am I out of my mind or does that
make sense am I crazy does that actually
make sense that I might be nuts but that
makes sense so I think I'm about to go
big brain mode here everybody hold onto
your hats because it's about to get wild
in here I actually don't need airlocks
either because if it's at the bottom
then I can have the co2 filter in anyway
then I have everything in one location
no one's got a runaround to deal with
fueling everything up these two lights
should invalid build oh geez but that
one's just there okay maybe they do need
something but okay that's that's not the
point have two of these here or one one
might be enough because if I actually
have this open or I make it air flow
instead is a bold maneuver that I'm
about to make theoretically it works
right I'm not too crazy theory speaking
this should work so it's it's there but
then I have a gas filter that's set to
no actually what I have is I just have
some deodorizers which is what I was
going for I have deodorizers right there
which you're gonna suck up all of the
stuff before it gets to that pump and
then that pump all it needs to do is
pump the air I'm not crazy but this sure
feels crazy okay you guys do see what
I'm getting at though right you guys do
see you see you see it right cuz I see
it and now I'm making way more oxygen
down there than I would ever need it's
actually overpressure it's extremely
breathable it's far too breathable
actually but once I get those done I can
base
destroy I'm not gonna destroy these
because I like it it's so pretty but I
can get rid of these and then I have
this that's essentially just my algae
farm and I can make it woman Road taller
if I need to I can scoot everything up
eventually but that that that is the
thing right that's the thing that right
there is the thing unless I'm nuts but
if also they don't pick up the bottles
of this it will still produce more
oxygen because of these sanitized
deodorizers here we'll clean the air and
turn it into clean oxygen and the water
doesn't lose water when it makes oxygen
right I don't know but I think so okay
and there there there there there she
goes what is that Oh
carbon dioxide but there she goes and
now it's just gonna pump oxygen in the
whole base because these things do do
all of them have light no not all of
them have light so the light doesn't
penetrate here okay that's good to know
I did I actually didn't know that but
now there's a ton of oxygen right there
when they start pooping out their
polluted oxygen it's still gonna get
sanitized and it's gonna scrub all the
co2 and then I don't even have to worry
about it over filling with oxygen
because the oxygen can just spill out
the top there's a bit of a food
poisoning problem I think it's from
watering it with this which is not the
best thing in the world but hey these
guys they can take a little bit of
sickness right whoa snazzy suit yeah oh
who gets it oh you could chew you can
choose gonna get the snazzy suit hey
look some you could choose on the wall
here in the ceiling you could chew you
got catch them all if you know what I
mean okay but now I can get rid of these
because these are what sir these are
what are polluting up my space these are
fine but I can get
[ __ ] okay uh let's get the mush bars
back going up again let's get mush bar I
love worse mush
who doesn't love mush I love mush we all
love mush mush mush mush I love mush who
doesn't love mush
look at these thing go they're just
gonna suck in every bit of polluted
oxygen and they're just gonna spit it
right back out yeah we're out of power
are those out of power oh [ __ ] did I
destroy oh I destroyed a wire didn't I
oh I did I did I did there we go and
we're back up I'm very happy by the
tickle there's a pickle I'm really
tickled about that there's a lot of
polluted water here hey can we uh can we
get a priority nine sweep on this here
just no not mop sorry yeah priority nine
sweep on this thank you that's pretty
cool we're making way more oxygen than
we would ever need I'm like hell yeah
yeah yeah
mechanics mechatronics engineering it
doesn't seem like there's a new hat for
that but whatever whoa nice hat tinkled
touch you need the carrying Turner
you're doing good but you need me even
more strength
hee-hoo astronomy sure evil baby face
you enjoyed a good diggin so you get
that um maybe I shouldn't have done that
I immediately regretted doing that good
old dumpling however you get nice farm
and there you go this is good
there's the first good thing I've done
ever in this game this is the first part
of where I've been like yeah maybe
there's some hope for me after all maybe
I'm not just a useless pile of poop
maybe I've actually got something to me
things are finally looking up for me
well there's some good stuff guys
there's some real good stuff sorry I'm
just really really happy really happy
about the Wow you're shining bright Wow
so far so good we're doing okay on food
not great I would love to do more better
on food but as of right now not really
getting that more better attitude but
you know it
what it is I guess the gas pump does
take a lot of power I probably could
have because now we're over producing
oxygen by far so I probably could have
done without that for now how let me
look at the I can see on the colony
summary which is very useful information
oxygen consumption 40,000 production
41,000 so I mean that's pretty good it's
right in line with each other so I guess
I don't need to rock the boat in any way
shape or form so we're doing good can I
get rid of this thing I don't need that
anymore do I
I don't think so anyway maybe I do but
you know for now I think I'm good oh
you're sick Oh No food poisoning evil
baby face Oh suck it up so what there's
germs everywhere who cares
maybe we should care I don't know about
that we're getting some people with some
sicknesses and a lot of germs in the air
but you know it's okay and I guess
overall the problem of having too much
of the polluted oxygen literally
everywhere is slowly going away very
slowly going away but it is starting to
be controlled it's go ahead move these
into storage those still haven't been
moved in the storage there's no one
sweeping anything I don't want them in
storage I want to sweep tup how to wait
I don't really want them swept up I want
them to be oh that's right because it's
full so I guess it can only do one at a
time that weird okay that makes sense
and 359 kilograms of polluted water
already how much water these things use
what the hell that's so much water
that's a lot of water that's a lot of
water I'm gonna I'm gonna do a thing
where I'm actually gonna get rid of both
of these and I'm only I'm gonna pair it
down to one because I don't know if I
need that many and I'm just gonna get
more bottle empty errs here
or not or or we're not gonna do that
we're not gonna do anything cuz we're
gonna go to bed okay that's good yeah
we'll just go to bed we'll go to bed and
also no no one's gonna no one's gonna
change out of their clothes whatever is
fine I don't care it's all good you know
what I'm gonna uproot these I can't I'm
losing water too quickly I just cannot
lose that much water it's gonna be
mealworms all around cuz Wow we cannot
handle this much not having what we need
temperature good ooh those things
produce some heat do they no no it's
just because it's just because it is
warmer down there I think oh [ __ ] we
need to close that off oh let's just put
a door there over there some items there
but whatever how we doing on algae good
we're doing good on algae we're doing
good on dad we're doing aha here we go
okay put the bottlers bottle and bottle
and then put the compost right there and
then put the nothing put nothing else I
think we're good we're good
okay let's copy these settings we'll
have a lot more mealworm we do need
microbe mushed we're getting stressed
you could chew is anyway popped eardrums
what's over pressurized the area over
pressurized well what am I supposed to
do about it
what do you mean overpressure ah it's
all over pressurized it's all really
pressure ii III don't know what else to
say but oh god please don't stress why
are you stressed
I'm unstressed you we need to research
we need to research something I we
haven't been researching anything
actually well let's get artistic
expression going on then I guess I well
I get stew artistic expression and then
fine art and high culture mmm very nice
dad that'd be good that's good we're
gonna definitely do that yay ma crude
yeah I give me gimme gimme gimme gimme
food yes please oh we are so in need of
food so I think everybody's eardrums is
gonna be popped because we're actually
making too much oxygen which is a new
problem that I never thought would be a
problem I never thought that would
actually be a thing that we needed to
worry about but apparently it is and we
you okay these need um polluted water
this needs dum polluted water we're
almost out of water there we're doing
good there we're doing okay here okay we
need more power is what we need we're
actually running low okay so things are
running relatively smooth but I can
already see the writing on the wall that
things are gonna go bad relatively
quickly here the main issue that I've
got is I'm in a negative situation where
I'm always losing something and right
now it's water I don't know what
achievement I just got but I'm still
losing water I need a way to get water
into my ass I don't know if there's like
a desalination this out oh there we go
desalinization for fireman process I
guess that's yeah that's that's what I
would want I guess eventually I could
get the fire pole to which would speed
things up just a little bit but that
comes later because I have no time to
think about stuff like that I gotta use
my brain power all dedicated to solving
this water problem so I'm gonna work on
getting desalinization in the mean time
I guess I could make some corner
moldings yeah that looks good yeah look
at that yeah this is worth it now that's
what I'm talking about yeah that's
looking good that's looking spicy yeah
Corner molding in the bathroom - yeah
bathroom kind of mine can't do they're
all right in this crap in the crap hole
in the canteen crown molding oh yeah oh
that looks nice Oh
put it in the crapper yeah okay here we
go oh yeah yeah now we're talking oh
this is something I've discussed
previously these these are the
conversations I've been having all the
time yeah I'll put it in the bathroom oh
yeah wall pod in the bedroom you better
you better believe we're gonna have that
and in the break room as well oh and
sculpting rock in the break room
I'm gonna look at it it's gonna be so
cool okay yeah let's get the art going
yeah that looks so good yes yes pretty
good this is definitely solving our
water crisis that we were having I'm so
glad we're putting our tax dollars
towards putting molding on the crowns
this is what I was hoping for it's
really hoping for this good thing
everything else in the base is going to
crap because we're spending so much time
building
why are those priority night that I did
not need this nah that's not a priority
nine build everybody that's that is the
opposite no I didn't need look we need
art but we don't need art that badly
that's not what we need we do not need
it that bad and this does not need to be
a nine he who he who in fact that just
needs to be a whatever you got like
whenever you get a chance kind of thing
oh yeah I can't even fit it in there
okay this was a mistake with get rid of
those hey a heart wow that's nice that's
really nice in there that's really nice
this is really killing it guys you guys
are killing it all right you guys are
killing it okay so so far so good we got
a lot of good stuff to look forward to
things are doing things are doing things
are really doing so I can't complain so
I won't I still am running out of water
that's still a thing that's happening I
still just do not have yeah and food
also still a big problem we're gonna die
I got a new colony Oh distribute a
thousand kilograms of oxygen using gas
vents I did that I did do that I did
that temperature how we do it how we
doing tip oh it's getting warm oh no
it's getting warm
oh it's getting warm probably from all
the biological happenstance that's
happening right there there's a lot of
biology that's going on can we fix it oh
we can oh I know how to fix this it's
real simple it's really easy now these
lights are meaningless
cuz I'm about to obscure the light well
you know it's okay because be a coup as
I'm gonna put an icy fan here and here I
don't have ice per se but I can make ice
even though that would not actually help
the problem please have food ah shine
eggs also good what happened to the eggs
that were there there were eggs that did
they not hat today do they hatch and die
and I didn't see are you cramped well
you know I can't help you there were
some eggshell okay well I guess they're
dead now we have no power why don't we
have power wise knowing powering
anything I feel like we need power I
just want some power I just thought that
maybe we could have some power here
hopefully we got our there we go now
I've got tinkle touch back on the power
generation which is good water so so
that's full up what we could do is we
could have another we could have another
desalinator
and I think in fact we probably should
so I'm gonna go ahead and build this
here we're gonna destroy this here we're
gonna build a second one even though I
really don't have the power for it cuz
that that that power line is pretty
overloaded as it is it's at 876 I think
it could take one more of these water
sieves which is good how much are we
doing on filtration medium we've got
plenty of sand so we got more than
enough sand this thing yeah no I can't
do that
okay whatever
like that I think it's always been one
pump to two sieves is the mathematical
relation so it should be fine and that
should just be it let me get rid of that
one from Univ this don't need to be
there so I don't have ice but maybe
there's a place around her that does
have ice it was cold over here no no no
no no it's a dream it's a pipe dream
it's a pipe dream that will never
actually dream I dreamed the dream and I
was an [ __ ] um there is nothing here
to help me it's so hot down here it's so
hot it's so hot and the heat is just
spreading why why are you doing this to
me why do you hate me oh and you have no
power because it's nighttime and you
didn't we need coal or something we need
what are we oh yeah I think we got we
did it okay so we did that we need power
and then we need a power transformer
fossil fuels oil refinery I'm not gonna
get oil anytime soon but I can do cool
at least for now I just had a thought
okay now this might be the world's worst
idea I ever had but the easiest way to
purify water is to boil it and otherwise
it'd be tough to boil something but it's
already over a hundred degrees Celsius
right down here because it's over a
volcano so I could kill two birds with
one stone I can filter water polluted
water which there is more polluted water
up here that I could get at any moment
it is not even food poisoning water it's
just pure water right there available to
me and I could send it down I could dig
holes right here send it straight down
here tunnel it under here boil it the
steam would want and then I would get
pure water out of it now it would be hot
water it'd be very spicy hot water I may
not want to use that because it's spicy
hot but I would have water and that's
what I want I could there's like a water
control thing that I could build the
something along those line on of power
my god my goodness
we just don't have enough power and we
don't have enough food what we need to
do is we need to be able to make lice
loaf no it takes water uh-uh
tofu nosh bean berry sludge okay how
about a grill I know we don't have
anyone that can really grill but maybe a
grill would be better because I know you
can turn lice into something good that
increases the amount of food it gives
without making - but I've got a lot of
things to worry about right now I've got
so many things to worry about more
things to worry about than I've ever had
to worry about in my life and I don't
know why 60 a grill only costs 60 what
the hell that's that's great that's
that's nothing I will survive I'm gonna
die I never thought that this would
happen to me oh we've got no water
I've gotta make a move I've gotta make
like Big Boy move this might be the
worst idea ever but I'm thinking about
boiling this it may be a terribly stupid
maneuver but I'm thinking about it I'm
thinking about it real hard and if I
just keep it nice and controlled the
whole time if it's just real nice and
controlled everything will be as it
should be and we will be fine
because if you think about it's perfect
the plan is flawless there's no way this
could ever come back to bite me in the
ass so if I just do as my gut instinct
tells me to do then I will be a-okay
oh yeah here's someone to tell me I'm
right coal it's a clear sign
it's clearly a sign cold
Santa wouldn't give me dull unless I was
on the right path it's perfect
oh why why have I not taken up animal
husbandry yet why have I not created a
ranch yet because I know that a ranch
would allow me to get some more food
because even if they only laid eggs that
I still would be better off I need to
make a stable I'm going to make a stable
I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do it right
here it's gonna be beautiful it's gonna
be a big beautiful stable and it's gonna
be perfect
it's gonna be flip-flap and perfect
everyone's gonna love it I'm gonna love
it
you're gonna love it we're all gonna
love it
what did I just research did I get a
coal generator it's a sign I just got
coal from Santa Claus which means in I
am on the right path path clearly oh I
gotta do all I gotta do is make a ranch
get the coal oil the water and win
that's all I gotta do database update
discovered geographical survey as the
duplicates got further out I've begun to
piece together a better view of our
surroundings thanks to their efforts
I've determined that this planet has
enough resources to settle a long-term
colony but something is off
I've also detected deposits of abyssal
light and neutronium in this planet's
composition man-made elements that
shouldn't occur in nature is this really
the target location
I don't know easy you're the expert here
hey construct the building outside the
initial starting by up I'm the best I
did that intentionally totally did that
oh [ __ ] what do you what what are you
doing there buddy
yellow alert get him out of there there
okay we're good
thank you I don't know why they keep
putting the ladder as a nine priority
it's not supposed to be a nine priority
is supposed to be a normal priority it's
supposed to be normal so then this here
this here okay good good good
great how big is that room room size -
underneath though that's cuz it's not
done yet doing that did I not research
Franchi oh I haven't even researched
ranching okay cool let's do it
let's do it and also let's make a coal
let's make a coal plant let's do it
let's make a coal I love cold I love a
coal plant let's do it let's do it let's
add more heat to this situation let's do
it let's keep the temperature rising
yeah yeah we're getting close to the
point where I can't grow yeah let's keep
doing it yeah let's keep pumping the
heat up pump the temperature put the
temperature up yeah reason I'm dumb too
I'm too cold in here I don't know got
our freeze like nerds off oh do we
toasty roasty my toes jeez come on give
it to me I can take it I can take the
heat this is the worst idea I've ever
had of and I've had so many bad ideas
okay now how many tiles is this cuz
there's a max 56 good okay I don't have
ranching yet but you know I will someday
so you know I like to dream
desalinization water so badly where's
salt water that's not very much salt
water it whoa okay found it tarp
quarter-to-quarter there's the ocean
quote-unquote that they were talking
about that's gonna take forever to get
to I'm never gonna be able to get there
okay yeah that'll come with time for now
I can't do that but whatever
oh so low on water so low on water so
low so full here why is this not powered
what why is no one powering this one how
are this one omelet gristle berry which
fry pickled meal
okay meal lice it does the same thing
it's the same amount that doesn't help
at all okay foods not necessarily the
biggest problem right now so I'm not too
terribly worried about that but I am
more worried about the fact that we're
not even powering it in the first place
see that that that makes way more food
that's a thousand to twenty eight
hundred that's such a good boost that's
a good
boosting calories even this makes more
why does pickled Mille not make anymore
even gristle Berrie makes it more okay
alright I can't worry about that right
now okay let's get the coal generation
fuel request threshold put fuel in when
it gets to 25 please because if this
isn't going that I'm not pumping which
means I'm not filtering I need this pump
going we just make this a level six
priority we can we are very sufficiently
full batteries are above the refill
threshold oh I'm doing it the opposite
way oh I'm stupid there we go okay now
we've got some power going now we're
getting better we're not great but we're
getting better okay so now we've got
some water flowing this is good this is
good it's not great but it's better
that's going there this is now done okay
I'm gonna end this episode here because
I'm on the verge of doing the stupidest
thing I've ever done I'm gonna unleash
the deluge of water and I'm gonna hope
that some weird miracle of
thermodynamics is gonna cool down the
whole thing in the process and I think
it will I think it will like it's an
exothermic reaction to have water
evaporate that's why we sweat in it
evaporate so it would cool it down
technically speaking but then I'll have
all the hot steam rushing up and I don't
know if that's gonna be I have no idea
when it's gonna start condensing and I
don't know if it's gonna just be the
cycle of evaporation and condensing over
and over again it was just gonna overall
make the heat go everywhere but we shall
see so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought
down the comments below
pray for me wish for me slap me whatever
you want
place your bets on how this is gonna go
in the next step so just place your bets
down in the comments below and I will
let you know how right or wrong you are
so thank you and as always I will see
you in the next video buh-bye
[Music]